-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well
tonight.
And now we're going to get
to the news.
President Biden spent the
weekend at his home in Delaware,
but eventually,
the Secret Service found him
and brought him back
to the White House.
[ Laughter ]
Republican Senator
Lindsey Graham
called for the assassination
of Russian President
Vladimir Putin
during a Thursday-night
interview on Fox News.
Say what you want about Lindsey.
Pretty bold to do that
on Putin's own network.
[ Laughter ]
At an event over the weekend
for top Republican donors,
former President Trump suggested
that the U.S.
should paint the Chinese flag
on its fighter jets,
bomb Russia,
and then added,
"They start fighting
with each other,
and we sit back and watch."
Finally.
[ Laughter ]
Finally, a way to bring
stability to the world --
a war between Russia and China.
[ Laughter ]
Former Vice President Mike Pence
criticized Republicans
who have offered praise for
Russian President Vladimir Putin
amid the invasion of Ukraine
and said, "There is no room
in this party
for apologists for Putin,"
quickly adding, "Sorry,
I meant no 'more' room.
We're pretty -- We're just
super full right now."
[ Laughter ]
Netflix announced yesterday
it will temporarily discontinue
its service in Russia,
in support of Ukraine.
And in even harsher sanctions,
Quibi announced
it will start up.
[ Laughter ]
Visa and Mastercard on Saturday
suspended
credit-card processing
operations in Russia.
And despite that,
they still don't take Discover.
[ Laughter ]
In a new letter
to "NBC Nightly News" anchor
Lester Holt,
former President Trump
complained
about his ex-attorney general
William Barr,
and said Barr was
"groveling to the media,
hoping to gain acceptance
that he doesn't deserve,"
which brings us to a new segment
entitled "Trump is Right."
[ Theme music plays ]
Trump is...
[ Clears throat ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Sighs sharply ]
Just hold on.
[ Laughter ]
Trump is...
[ Sighs ]
[ Laughter ]
I can't do it.
-This has been
"Trump is Right."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-The -- The
House select committee
investigating the January attack
on the Capitol
issued a subpoena last week
for Donald Trump Jr.'s fiancée,
Kimberly Guilfoyle.
The good news is,
she can do it from home.
They can still hear her.
[ Laughter ]
New York Mayor Eric Adams
announced last week
that he is lifting
the city's vaccine requirement
for indoor entertainment venues,
and said, "This is truly
an Arnold Schwarzenegger moment.
We'll be back."
Okay, but just
to refresh your memory,
when he came back, he killed
like a ton of people.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Louder laughter ]
Guess we refreshed
everyone's memory.
According to a new study,
the top so-called unusual phobia
for New Jersey residents
is the fear of long words,
which is just any word
longer than "Oh!"
[ Laughter ]
Organizers of the Oscars
have announced
Lady Gaga and Kevin Costner
will be presenters
at this month's ceremony,
so if you liked "Yellowstone"
and you liked "House of Gucci,"
I'd love to meet you
and see what your deal is.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, today was
Alexander Graham Bell Day,
which marks the anniversary
of the day
he said those famous first words
into a telephone --
"Representative?"
[ Laughter ]
When you got a closer.
[ Laughs ]
And that was the monologue,
everybody.
I, for the record --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I thought, uh...
I-I thought "representative"
was gonna crush.
I thought that was gonna be
a real,
like, "standing ov" situation.
Maybe that was it.
They could -- They could
sense my pride in it.
They were like,
"No, no, no, no, no.
You don't decide. We decide."